- Près de deux ans se sont
écoulés, mais les souvenirs de
frais dans la mémoire
des Américains.
(chaos)
Aprè
la commission d'enquête accouche
d'un volumineux rapport
de 845 pages.
Sa principale conclusion :
VALÉRIE BEAUDOIN, cherch. asso.,
Chaire Raoul-Dandue e e e e e et
et qui a mené au 6 janvier,
qu'on parte de l'élection,
jusqu'à la contestation
des résultatatatatatatatatatata,
il a été central,
il a été un élément central.
- This is a fraud.
- Sa dececececececececececececer
du scrutin de 2020 était
ititititée indique le rapport.
Par la suite, la commission
dénombre 200 gestes de Donaldten
et de renverser les résultats
dans des États clés.
Il a aussi tenté de convaincre
son vice-président, Mike Pence,
- We are going to the Capitol!
- La commission conclut que
Donald Trump a mis le feu aux
poudres le 6 janvier. C'est
qui a attiré les manifestants
à Washing
(chaos)
...et il n'a rien fait pour
les calmer quand l'attaque
popopoport recommande au
gouvernement de légiférer pour
empêcher Donald Trump, ou touter
des fonctions publiquesdans le .
- Pour l'instant, ce ne sont
que des recommandations.
répétant ces fausses allégations
de fraude électorale.
"Trump a gagné!!!", a-t-il écrit
sur les médias sociaux.
C'est maintenant au dép
de la Justice améric
de décider s'il dépose des
accusations criminelles contre
l'ancien présideotototototototo,
comme le recommande le comité.np
aux élections de 2024, estlulul.
- Ce que ça va changer, c'est
peut-être les républicains
les indépendants qui vont se
tanner d'avoir toujours des
scandales
- L'étau se resserre autour de
l'ancintntntntntnt, qui fait
face à de multiples enquêtes
fédérales. Lui qui est aussi
e e e e e e e e e e e e e e e es
aux élections de mi-mandat.(a(a)
Autrefois l'homme fort du Parti
républicain, Donald Trump est
vulnérable.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw